[Musique]
voici une légende
vieille comme la terre
a prise sur le bout des doigts des bois
une histoire remplie de mystères
soum est un ami zoo les qui vit seul qui
n'arrivent pas à s'intégrer il se
réfugie dans une amitié peu commune
celle des fantômes de la forêt
villageois eux ne croient pas du tout
aux fantômes ce qui fait que
l'intégration est encore plus compliqué
et on arrive ernement d'histoire et le
rejet des viégeois se fait très fort
il est parallèlement à ça il y a
la sorcière maaf h tout mrm bas le
dresseur de monstres qui complotent pour
envahir le monde des humains rien que ça
[Musique]
pas de morale dans ce spectacle joué par
deux comédiens mais il parle du respect
de l'autre teinté d'influencés
africaines la pièce est accessible aux
enfants dès l'âge de 4 ans
[Applaudissements]
des amis dessous mais c'est des gentils
fantômes qui sont rigolos ils ont des
voix un petit peu de dessins animés
voilà après les méchants sont peuvent
être un petit peu impressionnant mais
généralement les enfants les personnages
qui préfèrent d'enfler jalil avait un
petit peu peur on n'est pas là du tout
pour faire un spectacle qui fait très
peur c'est pas le but c'est juste des
veillées un petit peu ce plaisir d'avoir
peur et ça marche très bien
si vous voulez connaître vos premiers
frissons vous pouvez encore plongée dans
l'histoire de ce ou ces aventures et
celle de ses amis les fantômes sont à
découvrir jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
qui surtout mon
média